Ron I have a favor to ask of you.
3.
Please restore the memories of Codes 326 and
556 to their
original state.  Then it's a severe punishment, but considering the achievements of Kibi and others, let's just record it this
time.Return to the waiting room as soon as possible
.
Hana, it's not the
end of the party with a
certainty.  Hmm,
how much more distance do we have to kill before we can become adults?
[Music]
Baby, what are you living for?
I also stole zero ii's precious memories
Mitsuru and my heart
We can't think of you guys as daddy
When this battle is over
, please set us free
goo Even about the next strategy, let's chat  If that's the case, that's fine.